I've never thought of that and I don't  know what took me so long to think about  that idea  okay so not related to that but kind of  so we were at somebody's retirement  party and the the Caterers had a  charcuterie on a skewer oh what a good  idea in one of those like cones  instead of reaching in yeah yeah  everybody individuals  easier you don't have to cut it there's  a lot of good things that came out of  the pandemic ways to serve food and  stuff as Larry David pointed out on Curb  Your Enthusiasm you're done with the  skewer yes what do you do with the  skewer  or Heather's idea or Heather's option  you do what you got to do 6 16 here it's  Friday morning